I'm Robert Kasdan senior executive vice
president of Columbia University and by
on behalf of the University I'd like to
welcome all of you to today's summit
we're very pleased that New York City's
global partner summits have become
something of a fixture at Columbia
University every autumn some might say
tradition but for two hundred and fifty
seven-year-old University we use the
word tradition lightly this in fact
marks the fifth time that Columbia has
enjoyed the privilege of co-hosting the
global partner summit each gathering is
an opportunity for Columbia community
and each of you to hear from Mayor
Bloomberg good morning mr. mayor to
engage top officials from leading cities
from around the world I believe we have
seven mayor's in addition to Mayor
Bloomberg here today and to address the
most important policy matters of our
time several people deserve our thanks
before we get started for providing this
opportunity to all of us first and
foremost I'd like to thank Mayor Michael
Bloomberg 108th mayor of the city of New
York who has led this city through some
extremely difficult times and has known
that by unleashing the creativity and
energy of the people of the city we will
make it through strong
since october of 2009 the nation has
gained back one out of every four jobs
lost in the Great Recession in New York
City essentially all of the jobs lost
have been recovered and for that we're
grateful I'd like to make welcome back
my good friend Commissioner Marjorie
given the driving force behind
transforming and then growing this
important annual forum in which we
convened to talk about such important
policy matters
I'd like to welcome back again the man
we affectionately think of as the other
mayor mayor Feldberg mayor feldburg the
president of global partners is Adeem
emeritus of Columbia University Business
School a school which he led for 15
years we are grateful to have him back
every time he returns to this campus and
in particular for his leadership of
today's forum and finally professor
ester Fuchs of Columbia's School of
International and public affairs we
loaned ester to the mayor during his
first term and while in public service
she showed her extraordinary combination
of independence and insight that having
been said were grateful to have her back
I also want to thank Jeffrey Immelt for
joining us this morning as most of you
know mr. Immelt is general electric's
chief executive in the chair our
President Obama's Council on Jobs and
Competitiveness mr. Immelt has been
named one of the world's best CEO three
times by barons and since he began
serving as chief executive officer GE
has been named America's most admired
company in a poll conducted by fortune
and one of the world's most respected
companies in polls by barons and
Financial Times thank you for joining us
a key to the success of these summits
has been at the ability of its
organizers to anticipate the most
pressing issues of the day and then
focus the enormous energy represented by
the people in this room on the task of
responding to the challenges yet it is
surely the case that identifying today's
subject business innovation
entrepreneurship and job creation was
not a difficult chore and just as the
need for job growth has never been
greater at least in our lifetimes I
believe it is also clear to city leaders
around the world that turning to great
research universities and colleges will
provide one of the primary engines for
economic growth there are several
reasons for this is why this is so first
universities are large employers in
their own right and in most cases are
adding to their employment rolls not
reducing them columbia university is the
seventh largest non-governmental
employer in new york city with 17,000
full and part-time employees and over
two-thirds of those people live in the
city of New York second the campus
expansion which universities pursue as
they continue to make new discoveries
and educate more students create large
numbers of construction jobs and
full-time jobs for example the building
of Columbia's new campus and whisked
West Harlem
an initiative that would not have
succeeded without the support of Mayor
Bloomberg will generate over 1200
construction jobs a year during the life
of the project and result in 6,000
permanent jobs with benefits and with
career paths and third great research
universities continue to deliver the
scientific breakthroughs that lead to
technology driven startup companies and
establish new sectors of the innovation
economy we create the intellectual
capital that is really the bedrock of
future growth for example in less than
two decades columbia university has
generated 128 startup companies 81 of
which are still in existence and has
established one of the highest rates for
translating research dollars into new
products and businesses of any
university in the country Columbia's
culture of entrepreneurship is diverse
and far-reaching as reflected by our
Faculty's cumulative record of 4,000
inventions 1,800 patents and 500
licenses this pace of innovation
continues its not a relic of the past
each year on average Columbia manages
300 new interventions from faculty
executes 50 to 70 license agreements
launches 15 new companies and generates
in excess of 135 million dollars a year
in gross licensing revenue we don't do
this in isolation Columbia collaborates
regularly with the Bloomberg
administration the partnership for the
city of New York the new york academy of
sciences and others to promote new york
city as a hub of technology-based
entrepreneurship we at columbia
university understand as well that the
mayor's view that new york city's past
progress is traceable to the city's
history as the creative and intellectual
capital of the united states
and we certainly understand his call for
rededication to the city's legacy of
innovation entrepreneurship scientific
research and technological leadership
indeed columbia university is already
part of that resurgence with that in
mind it is appropriate that we gather
here today at the this university to
discuss the subjects of innovation
development and job creation this
morning we're looking forward to our
promises to be an informative day of
conversation about the most creative
approaches employed by cities around the
world for spurring economic development
to lead us off this morning please
welcome Mayor feldberg as I said the
current president of the New York City
global partners and a senior advisor to
Morgan Stanley dean emeritus of Columbia
Business School where he served 15 years
as Dean and a personal friend who I
admire and respect greatly thank
thank you for that warm introduction Rob
it's always an honor and a pleasure for
me to be on this campus first time I was
on this campus was almost 50 years ago
as a graduate student and there is no
greater space than this particular room
in our city of New York it is an honor
for me as president of the board of New
York City global partners to welcome
everybody here today the summit as you
heard from rob marks the fifth global
partner summit that Colombian has
co-sponsored and we greatly value our
relationship with this extraordinarily
world-class University we also would
like to thank the World Bank who joins
us as a co-sponsor and this event would
not have happened without the generous
support of GE and I do say very generous
true sport Jeff it was wonderful a
special welcome to the 13 or 14 city
commissioners and deputy mayor's who are
with us today were always delighted to
have so many members of the city
administration join us for the summit
today marks the 10th global partner
summit convened by the Bloomberg
administration as the global economic
recession continues the work of these
summits has become increasingly
important and I'm particularly pleased
that so many cities keep returning for
these summits in other words we have
cities that have come three four times
in the last five years because they
learn as much from each other and from
New York as they do in their own City so
they keep coming back which i think is a
reinforcement of the value and the
importance of these summits today's
summits will focus on what cities are
doing around the world to promote
business development through innovation
and entrepreneurship all of it focused
of course on creating jobs for the 21st
century represented here today our
international delegates from Bangalore
and Barcelona from Berlin and Bucharest
Budapest and Eunice Ares Cape Town
Geneva and Ho Chi Minh City Istanbul
Johannesburg and Karachi Kiev Lisbon
in Luxembourg Leon Montreal Munich and
Panama City Stock o tel aviv and tokyo a
truly global representation and i hope i
will be forgiven for singling out that
there were two mayor's here one from
johannesburg the city in which i was
born and grew up and a mayor from cape
town a city in which my family lived for
10 years when i was dean of the business
school at the University of Cape Town so
I'm delighted to have to South African
mayor's with us today we have a group of
other mayor's with us today and I would
like to introduce them we have the mayor
of Bangalore the mayor of Bucharest of
Budapest of Geneva and of ho chi minh
city as well as johannesburg in cape
town this morning it is my pleasure to
introduce and moderate a conversation
between two great innovators mayor
michael bloomberg 108 mayor of New York
City and Jeffrey Immelt the chairman and
CEO of GE and as you all know chair of
president obama's job council so I'm
first going to introduce Jeff Immelt and
ina will invite jeff immelt to speak to
us for about five to seven minutes he
will then take his seat on the stage I
will then introduce the mayor of New
York City and he will speak two for five
to seven minutes and take his seat on
the stage and then I will pose a series
of questions to our two guests speakers
and they would have a conversation
around these issues so let me first
introduce Jeff Immelt Jeff Emig
graduated with a BA from Dartmouth in
applied mathematics and an mba from
harvard business school he assumed the
top position at GE in September 2001 10
years ago his position GE as a global
leader in multiple industries including
power energy healthcare transportation
and infrastructure development Jeff
leads an iconic company with over
300,000 employees in more than 100
countries as a member of the board of
the robin hood foundation here in new
york city jeff has worked with other
business leaders on programs focused on
reducing poverty President Obama
recognized Jeff Immelt as an effective
job creator
when he appointed him chair of the
President's Council on Jobs and
Competitiveness in January this year
please help me welcome Jeff Immelt
thank you thank you it's it's easy to
say thanks and welcome to the two
mayor's Fellman and Mayor Bloomberg but
it's my honor to be here with you this
morning representing GE to have a
conversation about innovation and about
the city's role in innovation I just
relate to to frame my perspective I'd
make three overall points the first one
is that a lot of innovation in the
coming years will be around companies at
both big and small creating solutions
too big i would say social and
demographic issues and this is something
that really GE has worked on from much
of the last decade and we picked to what
i would call big themes one is clean
energy and the notion that we could make
innovative products we could generate
produce jobs we could do it economically
and we could improve the environment at
the same time Green is green and we've
watched that in 2005 and when we
launched that we had about five billion
dollars of revenue in those products
today we have 21 billion dollars of
revenue in those products it's about
twenty percent of our industrial company
and we've done that by more than
doubling our R&D and we've done that by
progressing from a technical standpoint
we've done that by doing this in every
corner of the world so that that's an
initiative we call ecomagination three
years ago we launched an initiative
called health imagination and this is
about affordable health care and we said
we were going to focus three billion
dollars of Rd on products that improve
cost quality and access in healthcare
that we felt like this was going to be
important not just in the US but on a
global basis and that we thought if we
could improve healthcare delivery at a
low cost and healthcare innovation at a
low cost that would help our business
grow and this is roughly half of the R&D
that we do in our healthcare business
it's allowed us to really lead in market
share and the emerging markets around
the world in healthcare but it's also
helped us really improve our presence
and
hospitals here so affordable healthcare
clean energy big problems like this are
ways that companies can innovate produce
a good return for our investors and
solve big problems at the same time and
I've convinced that's the way in which
these innovations have to be treated in
order to do this frequently you need to
offer a solution and almost all the time
some form of government is going to
interface with the work you do and so as
we've done this over the past six or
seven years we've done more work with
cities and in many ways cities can
provide I'd say the the most effective
form of government to partner with and
clean energy and affordable healthcare
so we've increased our effort to
understand how cities can innovate and
mike has been on the leading edge of
both of these both clean energy and
affordable healthcare smart grid
technology that you all read about
electric vehicle technology that you all
read about these are really City
solutions you know at the end of the day
you know we're working on Spig smart
grid projects in Miami Florida a big
Smart Grid project in Rotterdam several
of cities in China you know they're not
national programs that's two that's two
grand you need to focus on City
solutions so a lot of clean energy is
going to be driven by working with
cities and particularly in the area of
grid management grid productivity and
electric vehicle so cities are now an
important partner the other point I'd
make about cities is in the area of
affordable health care there's no such
thing it not just in the US but anywhere
as national health care we don't have
one health care market in the United
States we have 50 city health care
markets so if you're going to work on
things like affordable healthcare in the
US you're going to do it in cities in
our case in GE 15 cities count and those
are the ones that were driving
affordable health care programs in and
the place where we're pioneering is
really in the city of Cincinnati which
has the highest density of
GE employees and retirees so solutions
are a great way to innovate cities are
particularly good partners with which
with whom to innovate with because they
offer the the local solution that's
required the third point I'd make on
these big solution sets is that they
require partnerships between big
companies and small companies we've had
two innovation challenges we did a smart
grid challenge about 18 months ago where
we basically said to entrepreneurs and
startup companies here's our vision for
the smart grid we'd like your ideas we
got over four thousand ideas we're
making more than 30 investments in these
companies from out white or outright
acquisitions to strategic partnerships
and these are startup companies
similarly we did the same thing about
two months ago in in breast cancer again
calling out to the entrepreneurial
community to help us offer better
solutions lower cost solutions in the
marketplace so big solutions count
cities are great partners they're big
and small company collaborators those
are the three points I'd make just a
frame this discussion the last thing is
I want to shamelessly merchandise that
jobs Council this is the interim report
we gave to President Obama about two
weeks ago it's very specific it's very
focused you know we really set it up to
try to avoid the need for bipartisan
legislation permitting things that can
happen just with the private sector and
the public sector acting five big areas
infrastructure you know which is
something that creates jobs and is
desperately needed sponsoring
high-growth companies if 40 million jobs
in the US since 1980 have really been
created by high-growth enterprises not
not specifically small business the job
creation in this country are companies
like Bloomberg and Amazon and Microsoft
these are the guys that have really
these high-growth enterprises and how
can the US be graded that a national
investment initiative both to help our
exports but also to convince companies
to execute and invest here the fourth
thing is regulatory simplification
that's important at number five
education and one of the focuses
education is each year to increase the
number of engineers that are graduating
by 10,000 we graduated about 135,000
engineers every year China and India
combined graduate a million engineers
every year we want to create jobs and we
want to drive exports we got to change
that equation so that's the work that I
hope you've seen or can can download on
a job so I'm thrilled to be here today
and Mary I look forward to a great
discussion Thanks thank you Jeff I was
remarking to Jeff Immelt that this is
probably the 4th of first time that I've
introduced into an audience at Columbia
University but in the past it was always
to students at the business school it is
now my pleasure to introduce Mayor
Michael Bloomberg who like Jeff also
went to that other business school Mayor
Mike like Jeff knows a little bit about
entrepreneurship and innovation 1981
over 30 years ago he founded a small
tech startup company and gave it the
unlikely name Bloomberg LP I think at
the time mr. mayor you started with a
half a dozen people Bloomberg LP I also
understand that some of your advisors at
that time suggested that you give the
company a generic name rather than
Bloomberg LP you did not listen to them
and that's a good lesson for other
entrepreneurs in this room seek advice
but use your own judgment well you all
know the rest of the story about
Bloomberg LP it is now a global media
company that currently employs over
13,000 people in 160 countries since its
founding 30 years ago Bloomberg LP is
employed almost 30,000 individuals the
vast majority of whom live in global
cities around the world mike is a
one-man job creator today Michael
Bloomberg leads a global city of nearly
eight and a half million people arguably
one of the greatest cities on earth New
York City has approximately 300,000 the
employee
a budget of sixty six billion dollars
and a school system where more languages
are spoken than I've spoken at the
United Nations mayor mike has made New
York City a leader in a innovation and
entrepreneurship and in job creation and
I know he will be telling us more about
this during the morning ladies and
gentlemen please help me welcome Mayor
Michael Bloomberg thank you it is true
that Jeff and I went to another business
school but he went to undergraduate
school with somebody I live with and she
is a graduate of your business so we
have a connection anyways thank you for
that kind introduction and also for all
you do for our city as president of
global partners and Jeff welcome now if
I could just get you to move all of your
facilities from cincinnati to New York
mission accomplished let me also thank
Columbia University senior vice
president Robert cast and the Columbia
community for hosting and co-sponsoring
this event I'm on a number of boards
together with Robert and he is one of
the great corporate citizens does an
enormous amount for our city and has
been very helpful in working with our
deputy mayor bob steele and president of
EDC our Economic Development Commission
Seth Pinsky so Columbia is not just one
of the greatest universities in the
world that's located here it really is a
part of our city and their success is
our success and also let me thank my
sister this is Commissioner for the
United Nations consular Corps and
protocol I think she has the distinction
of leading the agency with the longest
name but it's also an agency that has an
enormous amount to do with the success
of the city because the diplomatic
community here in New York is a great
part of our economic success but also
it's New York's opportunity to speak to
the world until
from the world through the United
Nations and through all of the embassies
and consulates that are here Marjorie
also is this is her tenth year of
working with this summit and in my book
that means she scored a perfect 10 most
of you aren't old enough to remember the
movie 10 but that's another issue did it
would be a lot funnier than what the
response i got this year she had the
able assistance of Seth Pinsky and I
also want to thank those thank Columbia
and those who joined with Columbia in
co-sponsoring this the World Bank GE and
it's chair and without corporate
sponsorship most of these things
shouldn't work so while you can give
some business to GE and tried to give
business to the World Bank always have a
smile on your face at least and tell
people these are two great organizations
that really are part of this country in
this world success I also wanted to take
the opportunity to welcome
representatives of 22 cities who are
here for the summit including several my
seven of my fellow mayors I just had the
pleasure of talking with and taking
pictures with and exchanging ceremonial
gifts I have enough reading material now
to carry me for the next two weeks I
will report back to all of you of what
I've learned about your cities so thank
you for doing that together everybody
here in all these cities represented
represent people of widely diverse
cultures and histories and nevertheless
we all share a common heritage and that
is the spirit of innovation and
entrepreneurship and I just want to take
a couple minutes to talk about that
because throughout history cities in
every corner of the globe have always
been the magnets for talented and
ambitious people and that has made us as
Jeff pointed out the birthplace for new
ideas and new products that spur human
progress and fuel economic growth and
the crucial question that we face the
focus of this summit is what can we do
to encourage that process now despite
all the economic difficulties that
everybody around the world face
and to get that discussion started let
me just briefly suggest five answers and
then that maybe can get you thinking if
nothing else the first is both both of
the quality of life in our cities strong
public safety excellent schools
affordable housing attractive parks and
a vibrant cultural life we have to think
of those as economic assets of the first
order today financial capital and human
capital in the form of skilled and
talented workers are more mobile than
ever international boundaries mean less
and less and cities that off of the best
quality of life will be magnets for that
capital in that talent and we'll read it
dividends in innovation and growth
without the human capital you just can't
grow and that's always been New York
strong point the second imperative is
promote economic diversity especially in
today's creative and emerging industries
let me talk to New York a little bit
from around the globe people think of
New York as a financial center and for
good reason half of the world's equity
flows through the city every day but the
strength of New York's economy T reason
why we went into the last recession
later and came out faster than the rest
of the nation is that our many creative
and emerging industries are growing ly
rapidly in our city as well dan
doctoroff 10 years ago started a program
which the prescott a little bit tired of
hearing about because i worked it into
every single speech but a economic and
geographical diversity diversification
in our city really has made a difference
and we've grown in bioscience and media
and technology film and TV production
fashion and design today we have twice
as many fashion houses for example as
paris we also rival LA as the TV
production capital of america and with
those very high profile industries
supporting thousands of less glamorous
but very important jobs and areas
ranging from catering to carpentry they
all strengthen our economy and give us a
future it gives us the tax base to
improve services and it gives us the
ability to make the kind of investments
that will ensure our cities
for the future third cities should
actively encourage an innovation economy
and let me just like two examples since
many of you are undoubtedly marking and
making an outline of my remarks you can
have these as subtitles a and B I know
Bob tyranny is doing that with our fire
Commission cell Collison Sal Cassano
many young workers in financial services
firms suddenly found themselves out of
work in the last down term but they were
precisely the kind of energetic and
entrepreneurial people that we wanted in
New York so one of the things Bob steel
and Seth Pinsky did was create
incubators throughout the city places
with people thinking about starting
their own businesses in digital media in
fashion and other industries could get
reduced rates office space access to
business equipment and also very
importantly the chance to interact with
one another some of you may are going to
visit some of these incubators tomorrow
I cannot tell you how successful they've
been the firm started them have already
attracted 40 million dollars in venture
capital and they've retained to created
about 800 jobs with more on the way and
now for subheading be about a year ago
we launched a competition challenging
universities near and far to bring a
major new applied science campus to our
city we have offered land to build on as
well as up to a hundred million dollars
in infrastructure investments to make it
possible our reasoning well the startup
businesses that would spin off from that
campus and the jobs that they would
create would repay our initial
investment many many times over if you
go and take a look on so many high-tech
jobs are in Palo Alto or Austin or
Cambridge Massachusetts it is because
the universities there have graduated
educated young people who've gone out
started businesses and those businesses
have become the economic engines of
those areas and we want that here as
well the deadline for submissions you
should know was last Friday the results
were beyond anything that we had
imagined 7 outstanding bids from 17 mage
institutions including our hosts
Columbia University and early in 2012
will announce who has been selected a
fourth vital way to spur innovation and
urban economic growth is to welcome
immigrants for the past 20 years the
American cities like New York have that
have large immigrant populations have
also had far and away the biggest
economic growth this is not a
coincidence immigrants are enterprising
then more than twice as likely as
native-born Americans to start their own
businesses businesses that fuel economic
growth and provide jobs to Americans
who've lived here for generations for
example despite the difficulties of
starting a business in this economic
climate one area when York City has seen
major growth is in food manufacturing
there's been a fourteen percent increase
in such firms over the past three years
and typically such businesses are
immigrant owned and operated so our
economic development corporation is
actively working with them to help them
market and sell their goods more widely
and today later on you'll hear from
Jasmine Rodriguez a woman who runs a
city incubator for food industry
startups and will share her recipe if
you'll pardon the pun for helping them
grow fifth and finally cities need to
reform or eliminate policies that
discourage innovation and
entrepreneurship for example four years
ago at our urging our state legislature
significantly ease the tax burden on
self-employed New Yorkers many of whom
work in the creative sectors like
publishing and design and that has put
tens of millions of dollars a year back
in their pockets and believe me nothing
Spurs innovation more than cash like
that and we've also cut the regulatory
red tape that many small businesses face
for example we've created business
acceleration teams we call them that
speed up the process of licensing new
restaurants in the result more than 480
restaurants throughout the city have
opened weeks or even months earlier than
they would otherwise and if you're
wondering what 480 restaurants mean we
have about 25,000 restaurants in New
York City so it is a very big part
our economy and I urge all of you who
are taking part in this summer to drop
into a few of them as a matter of fact
I'm sure they can find a table for you
although if they can't I guess that's
even better news for us they offer food
to satisfy every palate and your sales
tax dollars will be much appreciated at
City Hall so thank you very much and let
me turn things back over to the real
mayor here and they are feldburg thank
you for those two compelling
presentations and I think that some of
the questions that I'm going to ask each
of you you've already started the the
answers but let me observe what both of
you commented on and that is that people
around the world and very much so in
cities have been thinking about the
anemic growth that the world has been
experiencing particularly the developed
countries over the course of the past
two years and that's the focus of this
summit how do we get out from under this
anemic growth and what role cities can
play in doing this so the first question
is addressed to to Mayor Mike Bloomberg
we heard about the innovative approaches
to business development and job creation
that you have initiated and that of or
even executed in New York City and your
last observation had to do with
simplifying the regulatory environment
in the cities of businesses could start
more rapidly and become effective more
quickly so I'd like to ask you what role
you think the federal government can or
maybe should not play in assisting
cities in innovation and in job creation
well I think what cities need and
businesses as well is consistent
understandable policies from their
federal government in our case from
Washington but it would be true around
the world
if the regulations are difficult to
understand or change all the time if the
tax policy is so convoluted that you
can't understand it if every day there
are new threats and new people to blame
for anything that went wrong in our past
it's very difficult to have a consistent
policy you need the price of energy to
stay at one level for a long period of
time for example otherwise will never
become energy independent and people
aren't going to make the kind of
investments to get us to energy
independence II and to clean up our
environment you need a tax policy that
everybody understands is fair but where
everybody shares in it tax policies are
used for encouraging economic growth or
discouraging economic growth in other
areas but people have to feel that it's
their money and I think too many people
just say it's somebody else's regulation
every regulation was put there for a
good reason but on the other hand the
totality it makes it sometimes
impossible to run a business or to run a
city government so it's not that we want
them to go away we want the federal
government to provide the services that
are appropriate federal defense getting
guns off the streets because guns are
cross-border or problem providing a lot
of the social services that no one city
or state could afford but when it comes
to business when it comes to commerce
that is much more a local issue and if
the federal government wants to really
help they can do the things I said in
terms of consistency and lacking
complexity and also deal with what is
arguably the single greatest inhibitor
to the growth of this country and that
is our crazy immigration policy which is
trying to drive business overseas it is
about as misguided a policy as anybody
has ever created
thank you I this second question is for
for Jeff Immelt we know of your work as
chair of President Obama's Council on
Jobs and Competitiveness what do you
think is the most important thing that
the federal government can do to help
businesses in cities create jobs in
other words I think both the mayor and
you have focused on the role that the
city has in actually being the source of
innovation being the source of
entrepreneurship and being the source of
job creation so what do you think the
government can do specifically 28 cities
and end and recognize the role that
cities play in the overall economic
machinery of the nation you know Mary
again I think you know might probably
knows more about this particular topic
than I do but I you know when we've
thought about it it's its infrastructure
entrepreneurship investment regulatory
simplification and education so those
are the big five that the jobs Council
has looked at if I pick two of them and
Mike hit a number of minutes peach
something around infrastructure okay so
a lot of that's going to have to be
executed in a local place now this could
be simple things like retrofitting
commercial buildings that would create
thousands of jobs in New York City to
get them up to more current standard
these are the people that are currently
unemployed you've got more than two
million construction workers out of work
the only way those people are going to
come back to work is an infrastructure
so we have a thing called the Better
Buildings initiative I think this is
imminently financeable in the private
sector but it's but it's standards its
regulations in some ways it's just
letting the city do its thing and
letting it go I think that's number one
this one I think is in the area of just
education you know we we have big
pockets of unfilled jobs today that we
just don't have people trained to do and
the best thing that the government can
do in the short term is to is to create
programs that can unleash community
colleges and things like that to get
people
trained I think mayor's are problem
solvers mayor's have more freedom to
operate they have more freedom to
execute they can move faster and that's
where do I go the last point I'd make is
look we need growth growth creates jobs
we need growth growth creates jobs we
need growth growth creates jobs the
government should get up every day and
say those words we work on so many
things as a country today that have
nothing to do with solving the problem
and and and I find that to be completely
mind-numbing Lee unacceptable and I just
think we we were not all in on this
problem and I just think mayor a lot of
its just tone we need growth growth
creates jobs I think mike has a hip
doing that really focusing in on solving
the problem but as a country I just
don't think we're all in on solving the
problem that starts in Washington it
goes through every business you know and
it goes through every city either of you
I you both spend a considerable amount
of time in Washington and you know all
the key players in Washington not so
much that's really I sell jet engines
really that's I'd like to it does
Washington understand the role that the
cities are playing and can play and
should play in actually being the
engines for innovation and growth and
job creation I would argue know if you
take a look at most of the elected
officials in Washington they came up
through maybe started in the city
government but they came up through
state government and then they would
argue it's not clear it's true but they
would argue moved up the ranks I don't
know why we don't think some of the
other levels of government are just as
important i would argue city government
is the most important in terms of
delivering services and influencing
people's well-being but when federal
government for example has a program
they distribute money never
two cities they distribute it to the
states and states if you think about it
have typically a bicameral government
one house based on population one house
based on geography the founding fathers
had a great idea but they never stopped
to think that you need both houses so
either one can stop things and as
opposed to both working together and and
so what they do is they tend to
distribute the monies around to every
place whether they need them or not and
you just have to go around and look in
this country the number of small cities
that have hazmat trucks where there's no
reason to worry about terrorism or
hazardous materials but everybody had to
get some and you can go right down the
list there's an awful lot of that the
bottom line is fifty percent of the
people live in the big urban areas it
will be seventy percent soon if they
distributed monies directly to where the
services when needed they would have a
much greater impact with those dollars
whereas the current process has so much
of a spread out not waste but a spread
out that it doesn't get to where the
real problems are and I don't think they
understand what goes on in cities may is
typically don't go on to other jobs and
the reason is that mayor's have to be
explicit mayor's can't have both be on
both sides of every issue you know where
a mayor stands yes or no the press is
there every day even in small cities and
the legislative side you can say well
I'm in favor of it but we need more
study or let's have a pilot program or
that sort of thing that doesn't sell at
a local level the public wants the
garbage picked up they want crime down
they want this schools better though
they want to reduce their taxes and help
their businesses get going I think mayor
health care is the case in point where
there is no such thing as national
health care doesn't exist it's done city
by city by city and if we want to bend
the cost curve if we want to improve
quality if we want to do all the
we have to as a health care system we
should be encouraging 50 marriage to
have great entrepreneurial programs on
what where we go with health care and
that's not that hasn't been a part of
any of the health care reform debates
you know we were big payer we're a three
billion dollar payer we've got hundreds
of thousands of G employees and their
retirees and I can look out over let's
say 20 cities the span of quality and
cost in these 20 cities is massive and
so that's I think that's a case where if
you turned that the cities are where the
action is on that one and that's one
that I think we get we've sub optimized
by thinking about it too much on a
national basis to politicizing well
definitely that yeah right lemme poses a
second question which rolls into that
particular question you're known for
putting in programs and strategies that
actually get executed on the ground as
you're moving forward and you're putting
in programs and plans and strategies now
that will be executed in two three four
five six seven years time one of the
challenges for for for you and therefore
for New York City in two three four five
years to make sure that that that the
strategies that you are have initiated
and already executed and the ones that
are in the process of being executed
actually move forward and get executed
going forward what are the challenges in
making that happen a lot of people think
when we execute some of these strategies
they prefer to execute me but that's
neither Hannah they're the things that
really matter are not the day-to-day
things that grab the headlines and that
the editorial writers write about they
are the long-term things that impact
whether we're going to have a future or
not they are investments in education we
really can't see the payoff the years
there the investments in infrastructure
this country has willfully failed to
keep its infrastructure up to date we
haven't had
new big infrastructure program in
America since Eisenhower is interstate
highway system but if you go back and
look whether it was the Erie Canal or
the Transcontinental railroads or you
know those kinds of things had enormous
impact and the problem with the big
infrastructure stuff is the payoff is
down the road you don't know how much
it's going to cost because you're
dealing through so many different
economic cycles and changes in
government while you go and do these
things it's very difficult to explain to
the public why they should reach into
their pockets today and have less money
for them to spend on the fun things in
life because that will give this will
give their children a better life New
York City I'm happy to say in New York
City taxpayers have not just under our
administration but under others reached
into their pockets today every single
bridge in New York City and we have
something like 750 bridges every single
one is up to stand it with the exception
of a few ramps on to the brooklyn bridge
and every night we create a traffic jam
because we're working on that fixing
that we built a new subway system and
extension down the west side which will
open up enormous amount of jobs and
businesses stores and housing and we
have to do with City money because the
state would not come up with any money
but the New York City taxpayers reached
into their pockets once again to do that
you know and you can go right down the
list a new water tunnel so that will
have a future all of these things but it
really requires an administration and
those that before me did it and those
some of them and those that succeed us I
hope we'll do it of leading from the
front bringing the public along getting
them to do these things even though the
administration that starts the program
isn't going to be in office when the
ribbon cutting is there they just are in
office when you have to come up with the
money and even though the public who's
paying for it may not ever even realize
the benefit the benefit maybe 10 and 20
is down and if you want to know big
things reducing bureaucracy Seth and
Bob's I
other universities coming here though
all of the infrastructure that we've
done the new roads those programs those
are the things that really matter but
they are difficult cells because
everybody says we can postpone those
till tomorrow what's the difference in a
20-year infrastructure project if we
start it now or next year and you never
want to start it in good times because
you're worried about other things and
you certainly don't want to do them in
bad times cuz you have the money but if
you'd go back and look at this worst
part of New York City modern day the
worst things done that had long-term
disastrous consequences it was in the
70s walking away from infrastructure
investments lighting the bridges rot
away not working on our schools all of
that kind of stuff thank you Jeff it
might be helpful if you could give us a
specific example of a GE City
public-private partnership in which you
GE has worked with the city to actually
execute a project and or how you make
sure that when you're no longer the cee
and the mayor of the city that you've
been working with that administration is
no longer than others how you ensure
that that that it executes going forward
as as as the mayor says you know you
could doesn't end when when the
administration changes how do you keep
it going and you have any examples of
you know better I'd say the best the
best the broadest and probably the most
noteworthy examples we have are around
the Olympics you know we're an Olympic
sponsor we've done this since Torino
basically the way it works is that we've
we basically have the infrastructure
space so whether it's Beijing or Rio or
London and we're able to come in and
work with a city and a very
comprehensive way and work on their
energy you know clean energy platform or
an electric vehicle project and we can
bring a whole solution so we bring not
just technology but financing services
all the things that kind of come with it
so you know we're doing we probably did
a billion dollars close to a billion
dollars of business in Beijing
we hope to do about that much in Rio
we'll do a lot in London and those are
the most big and fun now it goes all the
way to we've done with the mic a number
of clean energy projects we do street
lighting I mean we do a number of things
that kind of go with it and I'd say that
the one of the things i think we always
want the company to be known for that's
part of our culture is that we're good
partner you know we're trustworthy we do
what we say we're going to do and I
think that's the part of the culture
that lasts far beyond me in terms of you
know where it comes to working with the
city which is where we know how to do
solutions we use our breath as an
advantage but we have staying power and
and we'll find a way to get stuff done I
actually I think the great sporting
events are exiting examples of that have
known being originally from South Africa
and observing everything that happened
as a result of the world cup including
down here the far speed train that that
has legs that will go for a very very
long time we're almost out of time but I
I didn't know that there were pieces of
paper on the on the chairs and if any
members of the audience had questions
that they wanted to ask and accessorize
humours screen them very carefully so
we'll take a couple of questions from
the audience if you're comfortable with
that thank you sir so obviously we have
to take the first question because it
comes from a student at Columbia
Business School how can you help
international students to create their
businesses in the US and not in their
own home country so I guess it's very
fresh you like giving them permanent
status here so they can stay awful heart
there's literally it was talking
yesterday at somebody who has a business
in America but runs it from Canada he's
the CEO businesses in Seattle I think
and he is just north of the border and
this is craziness unless you can get
them to come here and stay here while
they come here for education unless they
can stay here they can't create
businesses here
after that you know entrepreneurs or
entrepreneurs they'll live through just
about anything they'll find a ways
around almost any problem but if you
can't come to America and stay in
America you can't do that and we'll try
to compete with other cities arguing New
York is more diverse and more
interesting and intellectual capital
your employees that you're going to need
to hear but the first thing is change
our immigration policies so Mara this is
from Josh plan when a company routinely
lets talented workers slip away it's
called mismanagement when America does
the same thing it's called politics as
usual at a time when growth is sluggish
and jobs are scarce and air which brains
are the only sure source of lasting
competitive advantage it's wrong that
America pushes talent immigrants away it
just is you know we have so many of
these things that again if you if you
thought Jobs was a crisis you'd wake up
tomorrow morning and you do something
differently and we we haven't started
this process of actually starting to do
things differently you know that's
that's that's you know we talk about it
or we you know I quite honestly I can't
read another op-ed piece or listen to
another speech you know it's just okay
let's go we got a list of 10 things
let's get some let's do to today you
know it is in that sides of the aisle
and both ends of pennsylvania avenue
however it is all of Washington they've
just got to stop this craziness and
start working together on the big
problems and this is arguably one of the
biggest yep okay interesting next one
comes from there yet
and member of the EDC so I'm going to
give it a jiff basically the question is
are we and in the end will we have to
concede clean energy technology
development and production to China well
I i I'd answer that like what I would
tell you ge is going to win ok so i I
don't I don't want you to I don't want
anybody to be mistaken I don't need we
are all in we're going to invest what it
takes you know we just opened the last
week two weeks ago of 400 million dollar
investments thin-film solar technology
because I know by you know by 2020 this
is going to be at least a billion dollar
product line I don't care about Solyndra
or any of that other stuff we do this
with no government funding we can do
this stuff right so I know we're going
to win now you know China's moving as a
country they have both scale and because
they have a central government and
because this is now a big feature of the
next five-year plan they're gonna
they're going to build solar they're
going to build wind they're going to
build electric vehicles and they're
going to do them in a scale that's far
vastly superior to the US so I just
think it's you know I had a boss when I
was early in my career and he used to
and he was a tough guy and he used to
say you know Jeff to do something you
have to do something right that's why I
feel about clean energy us if you want
to lead you actually have to lead you
can't you can't talk about it you
actually have to do things and because
scale is such a big deal and energy that
it's why I worry a little bit about
about us but I I think as an American
company I know we can win and and the
question is as a country are we going to
be able to create that same number of
jobs are going to be created you know
what we're having and again I think this
is a it's fair to be critical on
cylindrica stake in in india and china
between now and 2020 there's going to be
200 gigawatts of solar power
so let's not lose the force you know for
the trees it's not like something
inherently wrong with solar energy the
rest of the world is moving quickly in
that space so that's and during that
time we have presidential candidates who
don't believe in science I mean just
just think about it okay can you imagine
a company of any size in the world where
the CEO said oh I don't believe in
science and that person surviving
through the end of that day you kidding
me it's mind-boggling then you get one
more question before we come to the
break this comes from a student at the
School of International and public
affairs what role the sustainability and
investments in green energy technology
play for stimulating new york city and
other cities economic growth what role
does a sustainability and investment in
green technology well Jeff how long do
you have to kick at Jeff talked before
about if you were to change all the
boilers that burn number six fuel and
convert them to natural gas you'd create
a lot of jobs you'd also get rid of an
enormous percentage of the pollutants in
the air John Lindsay said when he was
mayor he'd never breathe air that he
couldn't see it was a very cute thing
but think about what you were doing to
people's lives and lungs today life
expectancy is a year and seven months
greater than twas ten years ago and a
lot of that's from cleaning up the air
or people who started to do it before it
is easier to attract young people who
they want to go to cities where the
cities are focusing on the future
companies use it as a competitive
advantage saying we are very
environmentally friendly we're trying to
clean up and do our part it's a very big
part of recruiting young people there's
a good economic potential and there you
know in this day and age no matter what
you hear from a handful of doubting
Thomases or maybe people are just trying
to milk a political issue it's move
environmental stuff the space has moved
from discussion and in
vation into actual action and people
companies today are doing things and
maybe not as fast as we would like but
New York City has this commitment by
2017 to reduce our the city generated
meaning city building city vehicles that
sort of thing by thirty percent the
whole city by 2030 thirty percent and
we're well on our way we're actually
doing things we are finding ways to get
big trucks off the road we're finding
ways to go and use less energy which
saves the pollutant is a very green
thing you don't have to clean up energy
it just use less but this country it
comes back the same thing we talk about
energy independence and then do nothing
about it we talk about helping people
who are sick and don't do the basic
thing of trying to keep them from
getting sick in the beginning and this
is a part of it it goes on and on so I'd
say half probably half of the clean
energy technology is best applied at the
city level the things that are best done
nationally like clean coal or a super
efficient gas that's best done on a
bigger scale but everything around
electric you know if you think about
electric vehicles electric vehicles work
they exist now whether or not it's a
fringe or a big a big part of the
consumer market all has to be decided in
cities it's all about infrastructure
business model that's not going to be
done federally that's going to be done
in New York City smart grid same way
building retrofits same way so there's a
big chunk of clean energy that is going
to be decided on the city level and we
see it you know traveling around I see
travel around the world I mean the
Chinese cities are really where most of
this is taking place same way in your
mics mentally to her and then everything
Mike said is true next generation this
is the way we recruit it's what kids
want to work on their smart about it
there they know and and it's in the end
it's not this doesn't require lots of
new invention this is really business
model innovation and it just needs some
local people to help drive it ladies and
gentlemen I promise to keep us on
schedule we have the
a long day to day as well as tomorrow I
think we've heard from two individuals
who actually I think have been it very
encouraging about the future of our
great cities and the future of our great
companies working together with our
great cities and we now ask them that
they should also address Washington for
us in addition to the city's thank you
my uploader can get